uh slim
you have invited me here today uh yes
actually i acted
acted as if you were very genuine people
texted me
no we're here you wanted to get a
podcast i would insect that i would be
talking here to
to we are talking you didn't say
anything about mohammed to job
this journey this road that i travel on
it all seems crazy over the years i
picked up thousands of tiger lungs
inspired by my story
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro was picky to the night east
moschino and versace no laces in her
cheese new millennium and you you were
i don't know i feel like in a way i feel
like you you know that we're not really
knowledgeable
you you say that oh you're not islam you
shouldn't be saying that at all you know
what i'm saying we
we still like we're muslim at the end of
the day but we there's more scholars
there's islam scholars people who know
who are very knowledgeable they go to
school for
and they know so we have we have a
friend we have a friend of ours who's
gonna
come and you know you know talk to uh
talk to all of us and uh
who's more knowledgeable about this so
come on in he's very educated so like
you know what i'm saying i'm gonna hold
it down he's a very good uh
friend of ours who's who's knowledgeable
and would know like he's just he's
he i want him to like be able to like
who is he going to
exchange like words with you as well
he's going to come in yo
where's he at what
in the meantime if you want to talk
about yeah your two-minute timer thing
okay we have a friend here who's more
i'm uh i feel like he's way more
i will not talk to muhammad he's really
he's my wife
you've disrespected me you've
disrespected no
you ripped up the quran and then and
then you're talking about your job
relax not about muhammad no it's not
about him i'm done
calm down don't be scared
you can hear
can you hear us can you hear us yeah
yeah can you okay as well
no it's all right i'm uh we're here can
you hear us here
i can hear you guys but he's gonna have
to unmute if he wants to engage
oh okay um can you unmute your uh
microphone i
could do that here can you hear us now
yeah
yeah yeah yeah now i haven't i haven't
been paying attention to what you've
been saying because i haven't i can't
actually hear
uh yeah so pretty much uh as i was
saying we were telling him about
um his childish acts that he was doing
yeah ripping the quran
and uh watching that guy eat the quran
and he's
trying to defend himself but he just
kept on mentioning your name adidas name
which i feel like is childish it has
nothing to do with muhammad hijab
this is about you disrespecting you know
the quran like what kind of there's
different ways to share your opinions
i have to i have to say something very
quickly um you have
adam and er slim you have invited me
here today uh yes actually i
acted as if you were very genuine people
texted me you know we're here you wanted
to get a podcast you have someone who's
not
i would insect that i would be talking
here to to
we are talking to the tourists we were
talking you you didn't say anything
about muhammad s
knowledge by the way you helped him come
here he helped us brother she helped us
i'm sorry we're not
i would not have come here if muhammad
was here because i needed a debate offer
to muhammad and we're here right now
listen all of that application
okay look if you look let's put all of
the insults to the side
and muhammad i just want to say one
thing before you i mean you can go if
you want to that's just going to it's
just going to say something about your
spirit here it will take something for
everybody about you right now
we respected you and we stopped
i mean what we can do now okay no
problem
well you have taken no problem let's not
listen to you
will you take it listen let's just
finish let's give you a chance to speak
give me a chance to speak
all i'm saying all i'm saying now
putting all of the hostilities and the
toxicities to the side
i will not put it aside oh well if you
can't if you can't manage that right if
you can't manage that then you can't
manage freedom of speech
that has nothing to do with freedom of
speech you're
i'm not being insulting to you right now
yeah i'm giving you
listen listen listen sorry please
you're a person who refutes islam
intellectually that's at least the claim
that you make
all i'm doing now we're people that have
much bigger platforms than you we're
giving you a chance
okay as an unqualified person who as you
are
to actually make a case against islam
yeah look at that tell me about giving
people
please please we're
just for a second just for a second stop
being emotional stop being emotional
be calm all we're saying is look if you
have a case against islam all i want to
hear now is your strongest argument
against islam
i will not talk to you say your
strongest argument we're saying
against islam i'm happy to hear it i
will i will not talk to you i will you
haven't
you haven't been listening to me you are
talking
to me you have to talk look you are
talking to me you have
you have an opportunity now to speak in
front of millions of muslims i will i
have made you an offer
listen you have a chance the floor is
yours the floor is yours
in front of you millions of people this
is your chance this is your chance what
we're saying is it made you
wonder listen this is your chance in
front of millions of people
listen put the officers aside for now
look look
you know what i feel like i feel like
you're trying to take advantage of me
and slim because we're not knowledgeable
mohammed powers he's a friend of ours
he's
very educated he is he is uh inspiring
why take it off your headphones put your
headphones on can you hear us
let me speak all right speaking speak
please do please
speak listen he said we just said
present your strongest argument
all right we're letting you speak number
one
let me speak number one i made it i made
an offer to muhammad hijab which was
very clear in the very beginning which
was that we are going to have an online
debate that is the fairest
discourse that you could possibly online
not about having this is not about this
look
well let me tell you he's all right he's
using that excuse right now because you
keep interrupting him all right listen
listen
you made an offer to debate him right
right
in the world it's better to have an
actual
because you are not letting me talk do
you see the difference the difference
between a debate would be that i
would have 20 minutes to talk mama to
job would have 22 minutes at a time
number two number two adam styles he
slipped
i have offered you a very clear choice
and said i will come to you for 10
minutes
in those two minutes and talk to ali
it seems like you're not really good did
i do it
look all i'm saying is this right
putting all of the
negotiations aside for the debate look
we're here here and now
people on your side and my side they
want to hear an engagement if you want
me to be
of all your respect all the respect we
don't like each other that's fine you
can put that to the side
you're here in front of a fresh new
audience of muslim people
all right we're giving you a chance as
someone who is a critic of islam a
polemic against islam
to produce your strongest argument
against it and what i'm going to say is
this
look i'm happy to stay quiet for as long
as you want me to stay quiet right now
if you say look stay quiet for five
minutes
stay quiet for ten minutes i will i will
be muted for that time okay
and then i'll have the same time to to
yeah i can't i can't see what's going on
what are you doing
guys to watch the full video inshallah
go check out my job channel and also
socially you know socially socially
profiled
by brother adam saladin's limited uh
slim uh inshallah blonde sisters this
boy got
finished he got finished with what an
unqualified week one little one
student and the irony oh my gosh the
picture here is
of his wife he insults the prophet to
desecrate the quran
and he cries because we mention his wife
may you die in your age
sorry guys anyways watch the full video
[Laughter]
oh sorry i forgot to mention one thing
you're finished